this morning you know the vending
machine area at the SiriusXM where the
vending machines are mhm so John blit
goes over to buy something at the
vending machine walks in who's there
Richard Christie but he's by the sink
you know how there's like a little
kitchenet in there right yeah Richard
Christie is a guy who didn't brush his
teeth for years he's in there brushing
his
teeth now it's a communal kitchen where
people buy stuff and he's in there
brushing his teeth and you know how
gross it is when people brush their
teeth they're spitting prepar ing food
Richard can you tell me why in God's
name did you have to go to the communal
area and brush your teeth explain it to
me well my mouth tasted weird and awful
for one reason I hadn't brushed it when
I got up I hadn't brushed my teeth yet
but why not brush your teeth at home
that's what I do the second I get up you
know the first thing I do is take a piss
the second thing I do is brush my teeth
well I was staying with a friend in the
city and I didn't want to wake them up
by brushing my teeth so okay all right
that's a perfectly reasonable
explanation although I think he could
have done it quietly you know what I
mean yeah shut the bathroom door I'm a
very aggressive brusher sorry I got a
lot of jum junk in my teeth why but I
mean you you're a guy who claimed you
never brushed your teeth during your
entire high school years am I am I
saying something wrong here a a couple
of times throughout High School I
brushed my teeth I used to get canker
sores but I had to take canker sore
medicine because my mouth was so messed
up from not brushing my teeth okay so
then why wouldn't you brush your teeth
in the bathroom where it might be more
socially acceptable and expected or go
to one of our singular you know we do
have a singular bathroom as well why why
why would you not why would you go to
the pretzel and and food area you know
what I mean you're so gross well and
because I'm I know this is going to not
make sense but I don't want feces
particles on my toothbrush yeah cuz I
rinse my I rinse my underwear in the
coffee maker so it's one stop away yeah
blit were you grossed out I mean I
thought it was great I loved every oh my
God I loved every second of it it was
the best thing I've seen all week it was
amazing we had we had a conversation
while I was brushing my teeth so I was
probably flying out of my mouth and he's
spitting into the sink that everyone
uses for cooking brushing his teeth with
such uh a zest for uh dental care and
dental hygiene it was he was going for
it like there was no tomorrow was
amazing I was asking John all about his
Thanksgiving dinner and it was no and no
and no and no awareness that other
people use that area for for kitchen and
cooking and well John John was so nice
he goes is it okay if I you know tell
everybody that you're brushing your
teeth in here and I was like why yeah
why wouldn't you tell people there's
nothing wrong with it thanks so gross
nothing wrong with it there should be a
channel dedicated to that just like 24
hours of just Richard brushing his teeth
and we ASMR yeah it's beginning to smell
a lot like
hit it must be Richard
christe there you go short and sweet all
right boys thanks for that and thank
you I got to go out in the lobby and
bite my
toenails they do they do need a trim boy
that Richard puppet looks good we got to
get that up on the app you you know what
Fred you should do a whole Richard
puppet show and just put it up on the
app it's a remarkable likeness yeah yeah
I want my ear wax on the back of Gary's
office chair yeah M it's like the
Richard puppet looks got that same Dopey
like look on his face it's like a half
smile it's crazy yeah and the yellow
teeth yellow teeth it's my favorite
there's a little too much hair up top
now Richard is losing more
hair I love the pile of Puppets next to
Fred it's so great whenever Fred does a
puppet thing we have a green screen
behind him so we can put him virtually
in like Richard's basement and there a
lot of good sets there I see potential
here for a sketch you know maybe
starring Richard puppet who else you got
El puppet can I hold up my favorite one
Howard go
ahead the Benji benj Benji it's blotchy
it's I love the it's got the blotch on
the cheeks it's so cute love about the
Benji puppet is that stupid hat he wears
so no one will know he's bald I don't
want anyone to see my
head here I'll see if I can work Benji
for you yeah work it oh there you
go where's my
beans garano my garbanzo beans what's
with the beans I mean is that how he's
losing weight he just eats cans of beans
only the juice Howard the Bean Juice is
low calorie yeah don't eat the beans you
just drink the juice yeah I'm telling
you it's it's pretty funny watching
Richard and Fred work those puppets I'm
telling you guys there's something there
hey Richard puppet you want to make out
yeah I think I'd like that
yeah can you taste the raccoon jeiz yeah
hey Richard get in get on the green
scham and see if Benji puppet can visit
Richard puppet Benji's wearing like a
shirt that's too small for him and belly
sticking out perfect sh too small for
Benji oh look look there's Benji over
Richard's
place hey Benji what are you doing there
I think we're going to blow each other
in about a half an hour yeah yeah for a
joke right no I like blowing guys yeah
oh you're finally willing to admit it
you guys I'm I'm giving you guys an
assignment take all the puppets and put
together some kind of funny show you're
going to have to kick me out of here cuz
I won't leave like the real
Benji that's funny I'm not leaving you
got to turn off my camera maybe we go
upstairs in spoon little bit later on my
wife won't
mind har I'm pissed for real I'm pissed
I won't leave
Harry all right how do I get rid of
those too got to do what you usually do
turn off that
mic